in big news that started last week
disgraced former Trump national security
adviser Michael Flynn has said that he's
willing to cooperate with the FBI and
congressional investigations into the
Trump Russia scandal in exchange for
immunity from prosecution
Flynn's lawyer put out a statement about
this saying general Flynn certainly has
a story to tell and he very much wants
to tell it should the circumstances
permit no reasonable person who has the
benefit of advice from counsel would
submit to questioning in such a highly
politicized witch-hunt environment
without assurances against unfair
prosecution of course prosecution could
be fair as well but congressman Adam
Schiff he's not buying it for now he's
the ranking member of the House
Intelligence Committee he said he has a
quote very skeptic Epis ISM about
whether it's even worth granting
immunity to Michael Flynn and added to
that it's not even really clear whether
quote Flynn can add value to our
investigation so Adam Schiff is saying I
don't know that we need what Michael
Flynt has to offer which is all a very
unusual situation right they may already
have the dirt on him so then why offer
him immunity Michael Flynn doesn't
really have any leverage in this
situation and it seems like he's trying
to create some if he can Donald Trump
publicly encouraged Flynn to try to get
immunity he tweeted out on Friday Mike
Flynn should ask for immunity in that
this is a witch-hunt excuse for big
election loss by media and Dems of
historic proportion hard to parse that
grammar but I think you have a sense
that Trump thinks the entire thing is
bogus obviously this is probably a
combination of both
ignorant sand Trump wanting to convey
the message that hey give Flint immunity
I'm not afraid of what it is that he has
to say we'll see that remains to be seen
Michael Flynn went on meek Meet the
Press back in September right in the
middle of the election cycle and said
that Hillary Clinton's staff members
likely committed a crime because they
requested immunity let's apply Flynn's
own logic from this clip to what he is
now doing people like Hillary Clinton I
mean five people around her have had
have been given immunity to include her
former chief of staff when you are given
immunity that means that you've probably
committed a crime
so you know I don't know how he can sit
there and say something like that with
all the the things that have been going
around just swirling around Hillary
Clinton yeah with her emails from the
horse's mouth right why would Flynn want
immunity hey well he said when people
get immunity
they probably committed a crime now the
initial reaction was WOW Flynn knows of
and it was part of a major collusion
scandal with Russia he's willing to
spill the beans and he wants to be the
first to talk to avoid prosecution
that's possible there is a more benign
explanation not benign big picture but
at least somewhat more benign which is
we know that Flynn wasn't truthful about
those conversations with Sergey kis lyac
so maybe he he just wants immunity from
prosecution for lying about that already
right and and we don't know it remains
to be seen but what's obvious is that
the general understanding is you don't
go looking for immunity if you aren't
worried about being prosecuted for
something interesting yeah it seems like
he'll have to participate in one form or
another maybe he'll get subpoenaed
anyway yeah we know some of the Trump
aids like Roger stone and Paul Manafort
are actually willing to testify on their
own volition but it seems like in his
case there may be actually something to
hide where maybe the other people are
able to be more honest and open we don't
know why we don't know exactly why
because we aren't getting the testimony
I mean if Sally Yates could finally
testify we might get more of a sense of
why Michael Flynn wants immunity to
begin with I'm sure that's gonna be
rescheduled any day now Pat right we're
I'm sure Sally Yates will get to talk to
us very soon Sally Yates apparently has
some very important information on
Michael Flint yeah I would like to see
that and we're not hearing from her and
it still hasn't been rescheduled send me
your thoughts about what's going on I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show